[Music]
foreign
dan cyder thank you for joining me
thanks for putting this together how are
you doing uh
doing pretty good i mean there's a
there's a cute dog on my lap i'm
chatting with a
fellow entrepreneur and i'm looking
forward to connecting
wonderful so where are you calling from
where are you now i'm
in hayes valley in san francisco
hayes valley cloudy day it was pouring
rain earlier
i was on a on a call with a friend and
there was just a torrential downpour
and here i am like trying to connect
with them uh it was a lot of fun
yeah definitely well you know i mean i'm
in southern california now and it's
still sunny here so
it's pretty interesting how you know
we're in the same state but we could
have such differing weathers
it's a beautiful day outside even though
from your camera it kind of looks like
it's very sunny
so i'll take your word for it
um mood tracking
what is it i mean you have you have
quite a personal history with mood
tracking from your article on the
huffington post but i'd love for you to
tell me a little bit about what
miso is and then tell me a little bit
about yourself and how you even
came to this thing uh those are
those are big questions those are huge
questions that we'll have to fit them in
in 20 minutes
so you want me to have a 20 minute long
answer to that question oh no no no no
let's just start i have many more
questions
um oh i think i think mood tracking's
one like an up and coming trend um
that most people don't realize that ten
percent of the population do it today
um there's like a quarter of american
adults
track their fitness with some sort of
automatic fitness tracker
and porter a quarter of american adults
yeah
holy crap and
two decades ago the concept of automatic
fitness tracking did not even exist
now that we have uh tools to
automatically track our moods like
isu we're going to start seeing that
same thing happening
with people with this group of people
who already track their mood
and people who want to become more
self-aware
and generally happier like doctors
psychiatrists they all recommend to do
it
um this is actually how i got into it i
was diagnosed bipolar disorder
i dealt with depression and anxiety
and my psychiatrists uh and therapists
all said dan track your mood but i was
so full of emotional hubris at the time
that i thought um like i know about how
i feel
i don't need some flimsy piece of paper
to write this down i'm not going to gain
anything from this and
how did they how did they want you to
track your mood like in what mechanism
they gave me a piece of paper and
they're like just write down how you
feel
okay and this was this was
quite some time ago uh
and now i i finally after
like stumbling on my feet um and dealing
with like horrible depressions and
hospitalizations that i started learning
that
the more that i understood my mood and
the more understood how my behaviors and
activities all impacted my mood the
happier i was
and the better i could control my mental
health and then i realized oh
these these these medical professionals
actually knew what they were talking
about um
oh wow we have technology that can
automatically track our fitness maybe
one day we could have stuff that can
automatically track our mental health
and that's when i set out on this
journey to do it
five years later we built an automatic
mood tracker and i'm excited to bring
this to support other people with their
mental health
so you know when you say when you see
automatic mutual i'm automatically
thinking about you know
heart rate and and brain waves so so
tell me a little bit about
what what is mood tracking and and how
do you how is miso specifically trying
to
trying to solve this yeah so misu
misu tracks mood through uh
our most expressive organ of our body
dogs usually
most expressive organ of their body is
their tail we can look at a dog and look
at their tail we can generally tell
roughly how might they be feeling
sure with humans we can look at their
faces and while it's not perfect
people have poker faces people put on
performative smiles
um it's pretty good especially if we
look at trends over time
and we found that misu so we trained a
model how do you go into it
um to predict people's level of
happiness
and sadness and anxiety through
their face as they're on their phone or
computer and we got
86 accuracy so just to get this right
the idea is that
the the model you trained is able to to
take
a and a still image of a face and be
able to give
some sort of score for your mood levels
on a variety of different scales
you got it and so the first thing that i
have to ask is
like you mentioned i mean people put on
poker face you know
i'm thinking automatically about theater
and people being able to turn
to transform how they how they seem to a
camera
you know there are people who could
smile at you on the street and you know
i'm at stanford now and one of the
things that they talk a lot to us about
is mental health
and sort of this duck syndrome that as
you ponder as you wander the streets
of campus you meet a lot of people who
seem okay because they look okay
but under the sea level their legs are
wobbling like a duck because they're
racing or they're stressed about
something
so where you were able to overcome that
that sort of fakeness
i think for the most part when people
are on their computer
doing their work or looking at reddit
um or i think zoom
is actually an exception to that where
people are i smile more when i'm on
when i'm chatting um and we
look at we learn what people's baselines
look at look like and then we compare
their current state to their baseline
and that helps
the one overcome that problem in general
that we just don't face that problem
generally because people aren't
performative while they're on their
computer
but then comparing to people's past um
overcomes the problem of like what is a
normal mood
which is a really big problem yeah
so the idea is that so it's not a single
picture that's being taken it's actually
a sequence of pictures that you take
throughout my
throughout my day to be able to also
catch me when i'm not
when i'm not looking at a camera and
aware that i need to smile now so that i
can seem happy
during this conversation you got it
and so so what's so what's been
happening today has this thing
so i know on the website you wrote that
that it has worked for you
is this is this something that's
actually working
yeah we we just launched uh recently we
had
a couple hundred people join the product
um
with a variety of responses like one
person said
um this like they're so excited to be on
here
automatic mood tracking is revolutionary
uh
and other folks are saying like this is
great uh
and they see a lot of potential in it i
think it's it's very much in its early
days and i'm excited to see where it is
to go
right so so i i'd love to hear a little
bit more about your your experience
with the bipolar disorder if you feel
comfortable of course sharing
and because um i you know generally when
people are facing these sorts of
challenges like depression and
anxiety and so on they're not that quick
to go
on the huffington post and write an
article about it uh
so i didn't i i don't know much about it
myself and i'd love to learn more about
what it's like
and sort of how can how can a product
like misu help people with
such such issues deal with them
um i hear i hear two questions in there
and the one is
like what is it like to deal with
bipolar disorder yeah
and then the other is how can mood
tracking help people
with their mental health sure um and uh
i i dealing with bipolar disorder not
learning
not knowing how to manage my mental
health put me through some of the most
challenging times in my life um
like i i
after becoming manic i
which i feel like this deserves a lot
more than five minutes to go into so i'm
gonna like
tr cut a lot of this out but i was
happier than i had ever been before
and one of my challenges with bipolar
disorder is learning that
sometimes there are certain states of
happiness
that actually aren't good for me that my
body will naturally go to a happier
state
and i actually have to realize this
and adjust my medication and adjust my
behaviors
that took me a long time to acknowledge
um
there's the aspects of like the
depression
and the anxiety that come with bipolar
disorder
um i went through some of my darkest
times where i lost
absolute like i lost hope i questioned
what is the purpose of
being here if i'm this sad um
why do i want like and this is
all that i can see continuing my life
why do i want to continue
there it's
not having those internal like resources
in my mind for how to manage my mental
health
um and like learning how to do it has
been
a decade-long journey and i'm going to
continue learning and investing in it
over time um because the opposite of
poor mental health is just flourishing
and that's what i look for so
i mean the one thing that struck me is
you're mentioning that you
were trying to sort of understand your
your mood levels and independently
trying to gauge your medication levels
and
and how you can treat yourself is that
something that
you can reasonably reasonably expect
somebody who's undergoing
you know these inner turmoils to be able
to sort of
gauge their own medication and their own
treatment
something that i found really
interesting um
speaking to a user of our product um
they said that they were considering
stopping taking their meds
and they they did they looked at their
mood data
for that week when they stopped it and
it just tanked
and they figured okay maybe this is
because of the meds
i'm going to try taking some more they
they went back on their heads
the next week they were actually in a
much better place
and it turns out that's that's a very
common thing to do
i've actually gone through that
extreme experience myself of stopping my
meds seventy percent of people
or seventy percent of medications that
are prescribed by psychiatrists or
mental health professionals aren't
consumed
by their patients so because a lot of
patients get them
there's horrible side effects so if
we're not grounded in reality
for how these things overall impact our
mind which we like
it's we're just kind of going blindly
and uh i think these sorts of tools can
help people make better decisions for
their mental health
unbelievable i mean so first of all i
mean it sounds like you you
the journey that you went through is
just tremendous and
obviously i i could never i could never
imagine what it what it's like to go
through that turmoil
and not having gone through it myself
and and so it and and i couldn't think
then of
of somebody better than you two to to
try and and solve this problem using
tech so now you're
now you founded a company called misu
and and you're launching a product where
you're trying to help others
that are facing inner turmoils engage
their mood
mood swings is this targeting people who
who have gone through similar
experiences or is this for anybody
that even the average joe that just
wants to know how what they're feeling
like
look i think anyone who wants to invest
in their mental health
um this is definitely appealing to them
we found that people who are more likely
to
pick something like this up uh
and trimesu are people who've used
fitness trackers
or track other parts of their life and
yeah i think there is there's just this
growing
a growing population of people who do
are interested in taking care of their
mental health
um especially now with what's going on
in the world
i'm one i'm like one of the biggest
advocates i think in the world for
for therapy and going to a therapist and
being able to
try and articulate your feelings over
time and having this subjective persona
give you consistent feedback and helping
you through some things that you might
not
be able and apt to go through yourself
and i've what i've always told my
friends is you know it's crazy how we
can invest so much time
in fitness trackers and going to the gym
and eating healthy and counting calories
and
so and so on but the amount that we
invest in our mental health
is is a minute compared to all of that
so do you use misu well i'm gonna have
to try after this conversation
yeah that's why i'm so happy that we're
doing this because i mean this is and
this sounds like something that every
person should do
and you know i'm i i was a commander in
the israeli military up until recently
and one of my responsibilities was also
to have people serve under my command
and
they tell you an officer's academy you
know you're not a boss
you're not just a leader you're a
commander you're
a you're a brother you're a father and
you're a friend all the same time and
it's
some of our responsibility to also gauge
our soldiers
feelings and and be able to raise some
red flags when things
when things don't go as they should and
uh so i def i mean i'm
already i'm a huge advocate for what
you're doing where do you where do you
see this going is this going to be
sort of um something that every person
will have on as an app on their computer
and phone
is this eventually also going to be some
iot that's in the house and tracking
their
do you know their walking habits and
sleeping habits
where do you see it going uh i think
first thing
is uh wherever it goes is figuring out
ways that we can be very respectful of
people's privacy
no matter what we do and that's
something that we stick to and stand to
today
um i think moving forward is like while
we
do very much care about effortless
effortlessly helping people
understand their mood we care about
improving it too
and i see this sort of thing like we're
collecting
we might have one of the largest if not
the largest data set
on how people's moods change from when
they enter an app to leave an app
um and we're collecting like a hundred
thousand um
sessions a day right now
and we're at a point in time where we
have platforms
like facebook saying that 60
of the time that people spend on the
platform it's harming their mental
health
600 million hours a day over
of harmful usage they've admitted this
now
yeah we have dozens of members of
congress that are trying to
hold these companies accountable to
reducing their harm
and the missing part is the data
they don't have the data and they don't
have clinical studies and researchers
don't know how to capture this data
passed a sample of like 68 which was the
largest which was actually the
research that facebook shared 68 people
facebook's not doing this research they
shut down their well-being team
like we have a really big problem at our
hands and it's going to be even worse
over the next
like couple months as we're as what's
happening in the world today
and so we want to support anyone who's
trying to hold these companies
accountable so they improve our mental
health
or they at least very much reduce our
harm because the net positive
they are they are improving i know i'm
going on a long rant
i mean honestly i have to say that it
sounds like you know i'm thinking of of
the of how
what type of ceo i want to be later on
when i build my own company
and this is one of those things that
it's a growing trend especially in our
generation
where we are we want to be socially
responsible with what with what we're
doing and while
you know business is important and
growth is important
i think that our generation of ceos is
becoming increasingly
conscious of how are we impacting the
mental health
and creating a positive experience for
our users and i imagine that as a ceo i
would want
to to take your services to let me know
hey this is what your app is doing to
your customers
because this is not something that i
could track myself obviously
it requires the expertise of of a third
party
that has the data of all the other apps
as well
yeah and i also know where i stand in
comparison to other apps
um simon
[Laughter]
i'm glad well let's get you using the
using it for yourself first
and yeah i i do see us heading to a
trend
where we have both consumers behaviors
shifting towards products that improve
their mental health more because they're
measuring it
um and then two is this coming from
government
um or new policy that forces companies
to reduce their harm
or creates a lot of incentive which
means most of the products that we'll be
using in the future as consumers
but if we want we can have them designed
to improve our mental health if we
enable the right permissions so it means
like
i see most consumer products in the
future being net positive
and significantly reduce their harm for
our mental health
and that's a very different future to
the world that we live in today
um and it's one that i'm quite excited
about did you know that you're gonna be
a doing something in the space is this
i mean because obviously i mean it's not
something that right that just any
person would think of naturally but i'm
guessing that because of your experience
it helped trigger this
i think it was two years
two years after two to three years after
my diagnosis
i wanted to give back to the community
in some meaningful way
i kind of looked around and realized
most of the
most of what we have for consumers is
i'm here to catch us when we fall and i
did not want anyone
if i could help prevent people from
going through
the experience that all standard of my
life that would mean a lot to me
um so i i wanted to create um
a system or help design a system that
reduced
the likelihood and would catch people
before they even get to a point where
they're close
uh on the metaphorical edge yes
wow well dan honestly it's it's
so great to hear and uh and i'm really
happy that we're
that we've finally connected and uh i'm
definitely gonna start using misu and
and i'll and i'll let you know what i
think and before we end i'd love for you
to tell me
three words that you think best describe
yourself
this is fun normally i'm very i'm very
like i appreciate concision
but i think the complex situation here
is like people have an impression of me
for 25 minutes
um and if my best described self is this
like who i am
um with my closest peers is this who i
am
on a public-facing presence like this um
so i suppose analytical might be one um
just like
reading from how i thought over the past
30 seconds
loving was another that i answered a
similar question to
recently and the last is
uh
playful i love it dan thank you
so so much it was great
thank you of course bye-bye